el endometrio es la mucosa que recubre
las paredes internas del útero una
biopsia endometrial es la extirpación de
una muestra de tejido del endometrio
para su evaluación
se puede realizar una biopsia para
detectar cáncer o células pre
cancerígenas
para determinar la causa del sangrado
irregular o para investigar problemas de
fertilidad este procedimiento también
puede diagnosticar infecciones y
controlar la eficacia de ciertos
medicamentos una biopsia endometrial se
puede realizar en el consultorio del
médico y puede durar de 10 a 15 minutos
sin necesidad de utilizar un sedante
el médico primero la palpar a
para determinar la posición del útero
y luego insertará el espéculo en la
vagina para abrirla y mantenerla abierta
de manera que el cuello del útero esté
claramente visible el médico puede
utilizar otro instrumento denominado
tentáculo para sostener el cuello
uterino y mantenerlo firme durante el
procedimiento luego pasar a un tubo
flexible largo y delgado denominado pipí
por la vagina y cuello del útero y
dentro del útero
la cánula de peep l está equipada con un
dispositivo similar a un émbolo que crea
succión cuando se lo tira hacia afuera
el médico girará la cánula de papel y la
moverá hacia arriba y hacia abajo dentro
del útero mientras succiona una muestra
apropiada de tejido endometrial luego
retirará la cánula de papel y colocar a
su contenido en un recipiente el médico
completará el procedimiento al retirar
el tentáculo y el espéculo
después de la biopsia algunas pacientes
podrán sentarse inmediatamente y sentir
calambres leves a otras pacientes que
pueden sentirse mareadas se les pedirá
que repose en durante 10 o 15 minutos
antes de retirarse
generalmente se prescribe un medicamento
antiinflamatorio tal como ibuprofeno o
naproxeno para minimizar cualquier
molestia o calambre parecido al de la
menstruación
el médico enviará la muestra al
laboratorio para analizarla los
resultados se le pueden proporcionar por
teléfono o durante una cita de
seguimiento con el médico